dann noch mal gegen eine wand gelaufen
dann bin ich einmal gegen eine wand
gelaufen und genau die luft raten was
das fünfte war
hey was geht ab und kommen bei allen
neuen video heute geht's einfach mal um
die top fünf behinderten dinge die mir
jeden meinem ganzen leben passiert sind
okay zumindest um die an die ich mich
noch erinnern kann ja also ich will gar
nicht lange dauern und man sagen es gibt
ganz einfach los mit nummer 1 jo also
dass du noch gar nicht ganz so lange her
ich würde sagen so ungefähr ein bis zwei
monate ich war auf jeden fall im urlaub
und habe mir so eine woche vorher neues
handy gekauft ja das habe ich dann auch
mit den urlaub genommen und hat auch
eine woche lang gehalten
aber dann habe ich irgendwie was
komisches getragen und plötzlich war ein
riss nicht in der glasscheibe sondern in
der led scheibe die scheibe darunter er
lässt den sts drogen ja also die letzte
zeit im urlaub weil ich dann leider kein
handy aber es kam irgendwie noch ein
ganz kleines bisschen schlimmer
und zwar habe ich gedacht ja zu hause
die reparatur so 70 euro dann war ich in
so einen komischen handy reparatur laden
und die meinen dann täglich 170 euro das
handy was in folge hofft aber dass es
für mini aber irgendwie ehrlicher dann
auch direkt das normale es verkaufen
würden passiert und dann geht es weiter
mit nummer zwei das war irgendwann im
letzten jahr und zwar so ich glaube an
meinem geburtstag das neue fifa kommt ja
irgendwie immer so
naja mitte bis ende september aus und
mein geburtstag ist am 16 september dann
habe ich meinen eltern gesagt ja ich
wünsche mir das neue fifa derzeit war
das neue fifa auch fifa 12 war halt
logisch so 2012 wie verzollt meine
eltern haben sich da nix bei gedacht
dann haben sie mir also genau dieses
fifa 12 gekauft und ich habe sie dann
erstmal ausgelacht als ich das geschenk
bekommen habt weil ich sie dann so
informiert habe dass fünf tage später
oder vier tage später keinen plan wie es
war
fifa 13 roskam die haben sich dabei halt
nicht so wirklich viel gedacht
eltern internet jetzt 3 xbox die halle
kein plan erkunden
somit geht es weiter genauigkeit und
zwar
hatte ich irgendwie in meinem leben
schon so ungefähr fünf bis sechs bis
sieben gehirnerschütterung
einmal bin ich vor der tür gelaufen dann
bin ich einmal gegen eine wand gelaufen
dann noch mal gegen eine wand gelaufen
dann bin ich einmal gegen eine wand
gelaufen und genau sieben raten was das
fünfte war
vielleicht hast du gegen eine wand
gelaufen bist genau ich bin von einer
schubkarre gefallen passiert halt ne
nummer 4 passiert mir glaube ich schon
so ziemlich seitdem ich auf der welt bin
ich verwechsle wirklich andauernd
irgendwelche personen jetzt nicht
unbedingt so was die namen angeht
sondern eher auf eine andere weise ja
also jetzt mal als beispiel ich gehe so
einfach mal mit so ein paar kumpels
durch die stadt und ich bin eigentlich
so einer der geht einfach und achtet
nicht wo die bleiben ja dann passiert da
irgendwie irgendwo plötzlich irgendwas
lustiges und ich will das dann direkt
irgendwann sagen und drehte mich um und
gab laura kanada und dann fällt mir
sofort auf dass ich gar nicht mit meinem
kumpel sondern mit irgendwem opfer rede
ja und läuft jetzt haben wir den punkt
nummer fünf da ist mir nix kreativ ist
mir eingefallen
deswegen ist dieser punkt einfach daran
dass ich mal youtube kanal gestellt ob
was war eigentlich das peinlichste was
euch passiert ist schreibst du einfach
mal bitte unten in die kommentare
so läuft das wasser schon wieder mit
diesem video ich hoffe natürlich es hat
euch so wie immer gefallen und er gibt
auch wie immer einen daumen nach oben
und unten rechts geht's weiter mit
meinem letzten video
dort ging es um marihuana in othello und
hier unten links mit meinem letzten
freeman das video zeigt beides ab
facebook app instagram alles und in der
video beschreibung abonnieren nicht
vergessen hier unten und wir sehen uns
im nächsten video handelt
im kopf